how do you make 300 billion dollars by
selling liquor well the answer is by
getting the CCP or the Chinese Communist
Party addicted to it and then charging
them a fortune this Probably sounds
quite daunting and a borderline
impossible but that's precisely what a
company called question has managed to
do
that name probably doesn't ring a bell
but question is actually the 25th
largest company in the world with a
market cap of 307 billion dollars that's
more than Pepsi and Coca-Cola which
means that question is the largest
Beverage Company in the world in fact
there are almost the largest food
company in the world as well only beaten
out by nestlight there are also the
second largest Chinese company only
beaten out by tencent themselves this is
no doubt quite impressive but when you
take a look at how much multi costs it
all makes sense a single bottle of motai
costs anywhere between 300 to 44 000
depending on the age
for a 500 milliliter bottle this
translates to 60 cents to 88 dollars per
milliliter for perspective even human
blood only costs 39 cents per milliliter
and that's just normal bow tie it's not
uncommon to hear about vintage motai
selling for more than a million dollars
this has a lot of Quito to grow to 20
billion dollars in revenue and at 13 a
billion dollar net profit every single
year with a net margin of 53 percent but
it wasn't always like this in fact just
20 years ago the entire company was
barely pulling in 200 million dollars
worth of Revenue and 75 million dollars
worth of profit this means that within a
matter of 20 years Cueto has managed to
grow 100 to 200x and this is very much
reflected in the stock price which has
run up as much as 290x even if you
bought Google at IPO you would have only
gotten a 50x return so how did question
motai go from being a boutique
Distillery to being the world's largest
beverage company with a drink that
tastes like rotten cabbage well the
answer is a bit of deception some
powerful connections and a lot of
brilliant marketing so here's the insane
story of question
[Music]
taking a look back question is by no
means a Heritage company in fact the
current version wasn't even created till
the end of 1999 but the same it cannot
be said about motai which According to
some sources dates back over 2 000 years
to 135 BC
this was during the rise of the Han
Dynasty not to be confused with the Huns
from Mulan the Han Dynasty is one of the
strongest dynasties in China's history
having ruled over much of modern day
China for over 4 centuries many of the
traditions and cultures that we now
associate with China today can be traced
back to the Hans so it wouldn't be
surprising if motai was also popularized
by the Hans The Story Goes that a
diplomat from the Western Han Dynasty
named Tang Ming would travel to an
independent Kingdom named nanu back in
135 BC during this trip Tang would
apparently enjoy a drink which he
brought back to the Han Dynasty
and according to Legends and quite Joe's
on history page this is the roots of
motai but what if I told you that all of
that was just a facade a legend
popularized by quecho for marketing
purposes you see according to historical
Scholars and Records there was indeed a
man named Tang Ming who traveled to nanu
back in 135 BC there's even evidence
that he did enjoy a drink there but this
drink was not a bow tie it was jujing so
the reality is that motai isn't nowhere
near that ancient but it's in question's
best interest to convince people that it
is a lot of the appeal of motai is that
it's what the greatest Chinese people of
History drank and it's the drink of
China this ideology and the Chinese
pride is what really sells the drink
because the drink itself is a violent
putrid and I can't understate that in
fact here are some reviews
imagine rotten cabbage ethyl alcohol and
a paint thinner Blended and strained the
first time I tried to motai it tasted
like engine oil I've never met anybody
even at the heights of alcoholic
derangement prepared to admit that they
actually like the taste none of these
reviews are that surprising though when
you consider that motai is 53 alcohol so
yeah motai is a terrible tasting drink
that has nothing to do with the Han
Dynasty the real roots of motai actually
go back to the much more modern Qing
Dynasty who were in power between 1644
and in 1911. sometime during this period
some Northern Chinese distillers would
apparently introduce some Advanced
Techniques to create a distinctive type
of baiju known as motai but again this
is mostly just fluff the reality is that
the invention of motai was on
ceremonious and largely unknown because
it wasn't really an invention to begin
with these Northern Chinese distillers
were simply making classic liquor using
their climate and English audience they
had access to it just so happened that
this climate and these ingredients gave
the liquor a unique taste which has
since become the iconic Taste of motai
so while cuicho likes to claim that
motai is some sort of magic juice with
the 2000 year history motai is actually
just some random local drink with a
terrible taste but none of this would
hold back mode Thai in the 1900s
[Music]
like with many popular products the
popularity of motai has more to do with
Optics than intrinsic value and the
Optics of motai can be traced back to
1915 to the Panama Pacific International
Exposition this Exposition was held in
San Francisco and is one of the most
Monumental events in American history
nine years before the Exposition San
Francisco experienced the worst
earthquake in its history estimated to
be a magnitude of 7.9 this Exposition
was designed to show that not just San
Francisco but all of America was willing
to fight through and recover from
anything as such this Exposition would
be marketed like never before and
attracted a whopping at 18 million
people the exposition showcased some of
the most advanced Tech of the time like
America's first transcontinental
telephone call in one corner of this
Grand deck physician though there was an
exhibit for Chinese motai while nowhere
near as impressive as a transcontinental
telephone call motai was no doubt a
heavyweight when it came to hard liquor
the aroma and The Taste was something
that the rest of the world hadn't never
experienced this not only made them
popular at the exposition but allowed
them to straight up win a gold medal
establishing China's presence on the
world stage this was the first time that
motai was linked to Chinese Pride but it
was by no means the last the event that
would certify mode Thai as a hood
classic was the Chinese civil war
between 1927 and 1949. this war was
fought between the Republic of China
backed by the United States and the
Chinese Communist Party backed by the
Soviet Union
the army of the CCP is referred to as
the people's Liberation Army and the
story goes that motai is what led this
Army to victory apparently the Red Army
soldiers drank mode tied to lifters
periods and disinfect their wounds
during the Battle of chishwai river
this battle turned out to be the turning
point of the bloody 22-year long War
leading to the ccp's Victory and as this
battle became legendary so did emotai
now to be clear we don't even know if
these soldiers actually used motai but
that's the story that's propagated by
question motaya and the CCP after the
war the CCP would have doubled down on
this image advertising that motai was
the favorite drink of the Chinese leader
Mao Zedong but it wasn't just a male who
enjoyed this drink either pretty soon
motai became quite popular with foreign
leaders as well likely the most notable
instance of this was with President
Richard Nixon in 1972 thanks to the Cold
War China and the US were basically
sworn enemies up until this point so
this meeting between Richard Nixon and
the tiniest leader is out and lie was
very much unprecedented and to celebrate
this Monumental event in Beijing the CCP
would of course serve motai we don't
know what President Nixon thought about
the drink but his secretary of state
Henry Kissinger was much more vocal he
said I think if we drink enough motai we
can solve anything this event cemented
motai as not just the drink of the CCP
but the drink of the elite leading us to
the modern day question
over the next few decades motai
transitioned from being a pride thing to
being a status symbol it was the drink
of millionaires and billionaires and if
you were hosting someone important
serving the motai was the standard but
there was no standard brand while omotai
came from the city of bow tie there were
several brands that you could choose
from up until 1999. in 1999 the CCP
would consolidate all of the most
notable multi distilleries into one
state-owned Enterprise called
while this did create a monopoly it
wasn't a very big deal it's not like
Apple and Google were merging rather it
was a bunch of local distilleries who
barely had a combined revenue of 200
million dollars
but then how did such a small operation
become the world's largest Beverage
Company well the answer isn't rocket
science one look at China's GDP graph
will explain a lot back in 1999 China's
GDP stood at 1 trillion dollars today
China's GDP stands at 17.7 trillion
dollars meaning that China's GDP has
grown at 17x for perspective America's
GDP has only grown about two and a half
X during the same time period
so question motai has acted as a sort of
index for Chinese world and the power of
the CCP in fact the vast majority of
noteai is consumed by government
officials in 2012 it was estimated that
half of all sales came from government
related customers president XI has tried
to fight against this one of the first
things he did after coming to power in
2012 was cracked down on the spending of
CCP officials this didn't momentarily
reduce the price of more time but it has
since recovered which just goes to show
how powerful the brand really is but
it's not all good news
is only relevant within China in fact 97
of all quatro's revenue comes from China
alone
while westerners do often try to drink
when visiting China they rarely pick it
up as a habit because it tastes like
drinking liquid razor blades not to
mention the price but it's not just
westerners who are shying away from Otay
either China's youth is also not so fond
of the drink primarily because of the
taste and association with older
Generations
currently the core demographic for the
liquor is 40 to 60 year old men so only
time will tell if motai will survive
through generations but as for the
imminent future it's not going anywhere
in fact in late 2022 Quito briefly
overtook tension to become China's
largest company period
so there's really no question that
question has basically become the
expensive alcoholic Coca-Cola of China
and that won't be changing anytime soon
in the end it's easy to dismiss question
more Thai as some sort of bougie company
that sells ridiculously priced liquor to
China's Elite but when we peel back the
layers it's clear that creature more
tired and more specifically motai itself
is much more than just that it's really
a testament to the power of branding
objectively speaking but Thai has
virtually nothing going for it it's a
byproduct of a random tiny City's
climate and resources but through the
power of a narrative storytelling and a
branding question
into a Chinese icon they were able to
tie together random events from over
2000 years ago to Modern events that hit
close to home like the Chinese Civil War
and asadong and while there may be a
longer term Trend away from Muay Thai
just like there is with soda potay is by
no means going anywhere but up anytime
soon and that is how you make 300
billion dollars by getting the CCP drunk
would you ever try motai for 300 comment
that down below also drop a like if you
would like to support our branding and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community tickets for video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one